hello vanilla
not thought every day you get to see a
totally hidden city that nobody else has
seen for centuries apart from us off
apart for myself and a few of his men
and a few of his men
you ready
[Music]
team chemistry abounds in Uncharted The
Lost legacy which is not surprising for
a Side Story - a series famous for its
AI partner driven gameplay while a
decade's worth of adventures and a
conclusive epilogue might place
franchise mainstay nathan drake on
permanent retirement now is as fitting
of a moment as any to wander and fight
through a new uncharted from a fresh
perspective with a roster of characters
as large as uncharted developer Naughty
Dog had a wealth of promising pairings
to choose from after playing through the
Lost Legacy it's hard to imagine a
better Drake 'less pairing than the
treasure hunter Chloe Frazier and
ex-mercenary Nadine Ross fingers crossed
that supposed to happen no just don't
get us killed the owner thought the
duo's vastly divergent backgrounds and
motivations create a dynamic ripe for a
classic apprehensive alliance and the
tensions that come with it seeking a
treasure called the tusks of Ganesh in
the western gasp of India the pair find
themselves racing against Asaf a
perpetually angry warlord who places
highly in the Uncharted villain
ruthlessness Power Rankings
it's a harrowing quest that's also rich
in exposition and substance much thanks
to the well-written banter between Chloe
and Nadine not only is it engaging to
hear them bring down their emotional
barriers of mistrust over time but the
dialogue eventually reveals the meaning
of the game subtitle which shines a
light on Chloe's personal drive to find
the tusk
the dense vegetation of India and it's
peppering of ruins reflect Naughty Dog's
amusingly consistent attachment to
jungles in uncharted in the lost legacy
the studio doubles down on tropical
forests with striking results
surroundings as lush and detailed as
anything you'll find in uncharted 4 are
fitting trivial Laden conversation
starters for Chloe and Nadine and
despite that the Lost legacy is shorter
than even the first uncharted these
insightful archaeological chats don't
feel forced or rushed why do you accept
my offer I'm not one to look a gift or
to know especially with everyone walking
to see before
I hear that but on the plus side oh
there's a plus nod
oh and people have low expectations it's
much easier to take the base in fact the
jungles also provided the ideal setting
for Naughty Dog to expand and refine
their open free roaming designs
previously seen in the much-praised
Madagascar map of a thief's end this new
open map which is the setting of two of
the Lost legacies chapters demands a lot
of driving but going over your own
beaten paths never feels like a chore
this is thanks to the wealth of
time-worn man-made remains orth
exploring and more often than not
climbing
these expansive areas and even the less
open levels are also memorable for the
host of combat areas that invite player
ingenuity and improvisation many of the
Lost legacies shoot-outs offer a wealth
of emergent and new gameplay
opportunities after every death and
retry it's not a mere race of exchanging
gunfire there are countless chances to
outflank a South's
army by making use of the myriad columns
and elevated platforms rather than
fighting enemies head-on it's a showcase
of easily executable simple pleasures
from striking enemies from above to
knocking out a soldier from around a
corner that's not to say there are other
ways to out with these squads clearing a
fully staffed patrol with a dozen
grenades and zero detection isn't only
possible but also a satisfying rush
playing as a ninja and triggering no
alert States is even harder but many of
the combat areas are expansive and
well-designed enough that such
gratifying outcomes are possible
one advantage of an uncharted that's
only six hours long is that it's easy to
assess the balance or imbalance between
the exploration gun battles and puzzles
the three essential components of the
series there's never been a more even
mix than in the Lost legacy much thanks
to the hearty helping of environmental
riddles
this new batch of quandary czar never
frustrating but will stump you long
enough to make the feeling of solving
them rewarding I'm taking you with me
uncharted multiplayer fans with keen
eyes will also notice the influence of
the PvP mode from a thief's end most
notably the introduction of c4 to an
uncharted story mode unfortunately we
did not have ample time to evaluate the
game's multiplayer and survival modes so
we remain intrigued at how well these
shared online components unified the
players from uncharted 4 and the Lost
Legacy Lost legacy doesn't signify a new
era for Uncharted so much as it presents
an opportunity to show the series from
new perspectives for which Chloe and the
AI controlled Nadine are perfectly
capable with a new playable treasure
hunter comes new settings and character
motivations wrapped in a comfortingly
familiar uncharted package the thrill of
playing through set pieces that callback
scenes from the earlier games is all the
more enhanced when experienced through
the gameplay mechanics introduced in a
thief's end
the initial hours of the Lost Legacy do
indeed give an uncharted Greatest Hits
vibe but a finished playthrough reveals
a more nuanced clever experience ranking
among the best in the series what battle
in which Ganesh lost his tusks I bet we
find these symbols we find the tasks
that Fraser
[Music]
[Music]